coup de projecteur sur un sport méconnu
et pourtant spectaculaire vous allez le
voir le horse ball un mélange de rugby
et de basket à cheval une discipline qui
exige rapidité et agilité pour le
cavalier et sa monture le parc équestre
de lamotte beuvron accueillait ce
week-end les quarts de finale de la
coupe de france découverte avec florent
clavet
pour pratiquer leur bol mieux vaut aimer
la vitesse et le contact
sous le manège du parc équestre fédéral
la rencontre oppose chambly à angers
deux équipes du championnat pro élite
soit les meilleurs joueurs français de
la discipline des les attaques placées
où on cherche vraiment à se retrouver
dans des positions qu'on travaille à
l'entraînement et à des phases de contre
attaque où on lit un peu plus de vitesse
avec le cheval mais il ya vraiment
différentes actions que ce soit de la
défense l'attaquent la touche donc c'est
pour ça que c'est un sport assez complet
ici certains cavaliers ont 25 ans
d'équitation derrière eux la règle un
panier égale un but mais pour être
validé une condition l'équipe doit faire
un minimum de trois passes avec trois
joueurs différents le horse ball c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des rares pratique
collective que compte l'équitation
collective ce qui nous permet de garder
des garçons parce que souvent à partir
de 15 16 ans on retrouve que les filles
dans les disciplines équestres et puis
surtout une des particularités c'est
mixte vous pouvez avoir des joueurs et
des joueuses et cavalières
des joueurs et leurs montures en horse
ball le dressage du cheval est
primordial
il ya un an et demi gabriel a hérité de
titi un grand poney qui a déjà fait les
championnats d'europe les très souple
donc à ce qu'il fait des bons virages et
c'est donc il est assez bien pour
tourner court et très bon en défense ils
poussent très très bien et en attaque il
tout en avons donc voilà donc il est il
est super quoi le horse ball compte
aujourd'hui 3500 pratiquants en france
avec succès les français sont
aujourd'hui champion du monde de la
discipline
[Applaudissements]